we start today with an update to an
officer involved shooting this one
happened monday near clark high school
that's off valley view and sahara and
that is where we find 8 news now
reporter victoria saha with an update on
this investigation
we're now learning the suspect's
two-year-old child was inside the car
the same car that the suspect went in
front of to fire towards officers
metro police were watching the car which
they previously stopped officers say
this time a man and a woman were arguing
and when they walked towards man he
started firing taking cover in front of
a car in that car it was his mother and
two-year-old officers chased him and
then shot and killed the man identified
as demetrius roberts
everyone's tensions are high in those
situations you never know what's going
to happen and it's just an example of
when officers go on a call it's
unexpected what will happen then and
this is a good example of that
metro says officer thuron young's gun
malfunctioned twice during the incident
he fired 16 rounds total and officer
joel blasco fired three rounds both of
these officers are on paid
administrative leave until they
investigate this incident reporting live
in front of metro headquarters victoria
saha live local now